le hemos dado mucha importancia a las
células digamos por sí solas y de hecho
esto es por buenas razones verdad la
célula es la unidad básica de la vida la
célula es la unidad básica de la vida y
en realidad son realmente fascinantes
verdad como hemos visto a lo largo de
varios vídeos y de hecho vimos que hay
todo un universo a nivel celular verdad
hay gran complejidad en cada una de
estas células que quizás no imaginábamos
antes de estudiarlas verdad pero ahora
podemos hacernos una pregunta cómo vamos
a pasar digamos de una célula a otro
digamos podemos pensarlo así a otro
nivel que pueden ser los
tejidos verdad cómo vamos a pasar ahora
de un montón de células ahora a nivel de
tejidos por ejemplo cómo vamos a pasar
de células por ejemplo no sé el tejido
de tu piel o el tejido que forman los
tendones o el tejido que forma otro tipo
de órganos como el corazón verdad y
éstos a su vez verdad los tejidos forman
órganos que digamos en última instancia
nos forman a nosotros a nosotros los
organismos verdad nos forman a los
organismos entonces todas estas son
todas estas son preguntas muy
interesantes cómo es posible que las
células se junten y se organicen para
formar miami o formar que a ti verdad y
la respuesta involucra a la matriz
extracelular muy bien entonces vamos a
escribir eso la respuesta tiene que
involucrar a la matriz extra celular
de hecho cuando cuando hablamos del
interior de una célula verdad y pensamos
en los organelos verdad dijimos que los
organelos no sólo están flotando en el
interior de las células sino que hay hay
todo un sitio esqueleto verdad que le da
estructura y le permite moverse o
dividirse transportar cosas verdad y por
ejemplo aquí tenemos nuestra célula muy
bien y aquí dentro en amarillo podríamos
estar pintando las fibras que forman
nuestro sitio esqueleto bueno de esta
célula verdad aquí tenemos el
citoesqueleto y en realidad tenemos un
análogo verdad para el exterior de la
célula que ayuda a coordinar cómo se
relacionan las células entre ellas
verdad y de eso es justamente lo que
hablamos cuando estamos mencionando a la
matriz extracelular muy bien
en realidad la matriz extracelular está
hecha de distintas fibras está hecha de
distintas proteínas y glicoproteínas
pero una de las más notables es el
colágeno verdad y aquí por ejemplo
tenemos nuestras hebras de colágeno
estas son hebras de colágeno muy bien y
en realidad es la proteína más común por
ejemplo en los mamíferos verdad así que
aquí tenemos por ejemplo el colágeno
verdad que es lo que forma a este tipo
de hebras verdad y se tiene una
estimación de que aproximadamente el 30
por ciento de las proteínas de los
mamíferos proteínas déjenme hacerlo a
bajo el 30 por ciento de las proteínas
en mamíferos en mamíferos es en realidad
son justamente el colágeno verdad
entonces estamos pensando que el 30 por
ciento de las proteínas en los mamíferos
en realidad corresponde al colágeno
verdad y mucho del colágeno está digamos
ayudando a hacer estas hebras que he
pintado aquí verdad que conforman la
matriz extracelular y no es la única
proteína presente hoy claramente verdad
entonces aquí por ejemplo tenemos varias
células aquí tenemos otra célula tenemos
otra célula tenemos varias células ok y
como las dibuje parecen digamos que
estuvieran fijas verdad y que están
adaptadas a la matriz extracelular y
esto ayuda de cierta forma a posicionar
las por un lado esto es cierto verdad
que el colágeno y otras cosas ayudan a
las células a posicionarse pero también
las ayudan a informar a las células por
ejemplo de cuando crecer cuando
dividirse y no sé quizás cuando morir o
producir cierto tipo de moléculas
así que para entender un poco más qué es
lo que ocurre digamos si hiciéramos un
acercamiento a esta parte de la célula
en realidad estaríamos hablando de una
parte de la membrana celular verdad
entonces obtendríamos esta imagen que
digamos prácticamente abarca toda
nuestra pantalla verdad aquí tendríamos
esta imagen si hiciéramos un
acercamiento tan solo de este pequeño
pedacito de membrana celular verdad así
que por ejemplo de este lado tendríamos
el interior de la célula entonces este
es el interior d
célula muy bien y por supuesto aquí
tenemos la actina verdad que nosotros ya
en vídeos anteriores hemos dicho que la
actina forma micro filamentos y que son
parte fundamental del citoesqueleto muy
bien así que también por ejemplo tenemos
el colágeno aquí afuera verdad que forma
parte
genera estructuras de la matriz
extracelular verdad y por ejemplo todo
esto se une gracias a las integrinas
aunque las integrinas son cierto tipo de
proteínas y éstas están encajadas en la
membrana de las células verdad y digamos
que por otras fibras de fibronectina por
ejemplo pueden atarse a la matriz
extracelular verdad y esto es muy muy
interesante verdad porque estamos
hablando de que estamos conectando
estructuras extras celulares como es la
matriz verdad la matriz extracelular con
el citoesqueleto que está dentro de la
célula a través de las proteínas verdad
trae
de las proteínas es como los estamos
uniendo y como mencioné estas proteínas
pueden ayudar a mantener las cosas
juntas pero también se utilizan para
indicar señales por ejemplo pueden
pueden detectar tensión pueden señalizar
a la célula de activarse o desactivarse
en formas no sé quizás muy interesantes
verdad ahora bien incluso en cursos
introductorios de biología puede uno
tener no sé cómo la sensación de que
todo esto se entiende muy bien digamos
que que aquí tenemos la integridad que
está conectando al al citoesqueleto
verdad a través de los de los
microfilamentos de actina con las hebras
de colágeno verdad y que tenemos
fibronectina aquí que nos está ayudando
a todo este proceso pareciera que todo
esto se comprende bien pero la realidad
es otra y si nos preguntamos cómo es que
realmente todo esto se conecta cómo es
que se detectan las señales con estas
estructuras verdad con con base en la
atención o el estrés
todo esto en realidad es un
área de investigación abierta así que
por ejemplo sitúa ondas un poco más por
tu cuenta digamos puedes buscar en
internet y de hecho te invito a que
realmente lo hagas verás que hay muchos
artículos de investigación que son
recientes donde la gente publica cómo es
que las integrinas funcionan o cómo es
que se dan señales a la célula verdad o
cómo es que se unen el citoesqueleto con
la matriz extracelular verdad todas
estas son áreas de investigación y
seguirán investigando porque siempre hay
más preguntas sobre cómo estas
estructuras increíblemente complejas se
relacionan entre ellas cómo es que cómo
es que digamos saben qué hacer y cómo es
que estos mecanismos de señalización
funcionan son preguntas que siguen hasta
cierto punto abiertas verdad así que
espero que esto te haya dado una
apreciación de la complejidad que te
hace ser quien eres verdad ya hemos
hablado de que las células son complejas
pero pero ahora no sólo eso sino que se
relacionan con esta matriz extracelular
verdad y que eso les ayuda a construir
tejidos y hasta cierto punto
a que la célula pueda vivir en comunidad
y que se relacionen digamos con
señalizaciones desde su ambiente y por
supuesto aquí solo he dibujado una sola
integrina pero puede haber varias a lo
largo de la membrana así como muchos
otros tipos de proteínas verdad lo
fascinante de las membranas celulares es
que no sólo son digamos esta bicapa de
fosfolípidos sino que tienen todo tipo
de proteínas que pueden funcionar como
receptores y que permiten a cierto tipo
de moléculas por ejemplo entrar o salir
verdad podemos podemos pensarlas como si
fueran pequeñas ciudades que interactúan
con su propio ambiente